hello everyone
thanks for joining uh we're on uh
facebook
youtube and linkedin so wherever you are
in the virtual world
welcome um this is actually really
really exciting to me for me
uh because um we're launching a new book
called the power
of giving away power by matthew barzin
on optimism press
so i'll tell you the history of optimism
press it's a nice story i kept meeting
these wonderful people
and saying you should write a book and i
would introduce them to my publisher
and um all the books that i recommended
to them like people really liked and
were getting good value of them i would
go to conferences
and i'd hear people quoting them and i i
called the publisher i called penguin
said why don't we just do this together
let's start our own imprint which
basically means our own little
publishing company
and let's just publish our own books um
and that's what we did so we started our
own little publishing company called
optimism press
um where i get to find amazing people
who i believe their ideas
are big ideas who are having profound
impact and can have profound impact on
the world
and if if you follow our work i'm sure
you're part of the movement you know
the vision the vision is to create a
world in which the vast majority of
people wake up
every single morning inspired feel safe
wherever they are and end the day
fulfilled by the work that they do
and matthew barzin's book the power of
giving away power i believe is one of
those
pieces of the jigsaw puzzle that we need
to build
that world so i thought what fun to
invite matthew
to talk about it i met matthew a bunch
of years ago
in london when he was still the u.s
ambassador to great britain
and he invited me i hadn't met him
before and he invited me to come speak
to the embassy and some students and we
got along
is basically what happened and i loved
his thinking and every time he would
start talking
i would take notes and i found him
incredibly wonderful and down to earth
and quite frankly we became friends and
he's uh
he's uh now back in the united states
living in louisville kentucky
and we thought we need to write down
some of those ideas more formally
because they're so good hence the power
of giving away power so without further
ado i'm going to bring matthew on if you
have any questions please drop them in
the chat
and we will answer all of your questions
matthew barzen hello simon
hello everyone well i am uh
you know blushing for your kind words i
am
it's just great to be here with you and
all of my fellow fans of simon sinek and
fellow beneficiaries of your why
my friend that is why i am sitting here
in louisville kentucky
live streaming with this great group
congratulations you are now a published
author
yeah how about that how does that feel
oh it well i learned from someone named
simon sinek that the feeling of
nervousness and the feeling
of excitement are actually physically or
physiologically i think you said the
same feeling it's just how we
choose to interpret that so i
i am excited and nervous so
as i was saying before you're one of
those rare people that
you're humble you're down to earth and
and almost every time you would start
talking you would start philosophizing i
found myself frantically looking
um for a pen and paper to start taking
notes on the things you said
and so what a personal thrill it is for
me
that i get to take some of that big
thinking that you have about how to
reorganize the world and more
importantly
how to reorganize our businesses and
organizations um
uh to to to be a more equitable world in
the world that you imagine i
it's it's wonderful uh so thank you
thank you thank you for letting me bring
your
your your ideas uh to life and to the
world
um without any further ado i would love
to jump into the questions
if i may um i have a bunch here that
people pre-submitted and we'll take some
live ones as they show up as well
so matthew here's one uh from uh
dana b uh what does that say
did i did i lose sound matthew's writing
writing notes to me
did we lose matthew
where it looks like we're having
connection issues so in the meantime
um i can tell you a little bit about uh
the power of giving away power
so um i'll share one of the principles
that's in the book that i absolutely
love while we figure out the
uh the tech issue oh
he's back but i'm back can you hear me
we can hear you perfectly i was about to
start explaining your thinking okay
good let's jump right in um okay wants
to know
what exactly is the constellation
mindset
and how does it apply to companies
well the constellation mindset is
a way of seeing thinking feeling and
behaving
about how you see yourself and the
people around you and to cut right to it
it's about seeing yourself as a star and
more importantly seeing
everyone around you as a star and then
the game becomes well how do we make
connections between us to build
something more useful
more powerful than any of us could alone
and we'll get into this later but
that's in contrast yeah so sorry to
interrupt but i i want to give a little
context for where the
the constellation mindset came from and
so i know
you you have this rant that i absolutely
love when you talk about the pyramid
and how we organize top down and and how
we've responded to that
can you start there because i think
it'll contextualize what what the
constellation is
that's a good point so before we get
into consolation mindset we should talk
about its alternative which as simon
said i think
too often is kind of our default setting
here's what i mean we all got the memo
that top-down leadership doesn't work
right
so what we end up doing is we've like i
know we think we do the opposite let's
be bottom up
right and that does feel better for like
a second but think about it
the bottom-up mentality forces us into
one of two modes
either you're thinking of other people
as beneath you
or you think of yourself as beneath
someone else this is just the exact same
pyramid shape
uh in reverse order it's hierarchy by
another name
so we cannot we do not escape this
pyramid mindset when we turn to bottom
up
we need to do something different now
the the alternative
once you do a sk you realize that then
you escape that and you're like well
okay well maybe i'm just sort of on my
own
the world is just i'm a mill one of a
million stars in the night sky and i
guess that's
the way it is and i'm giving up all
order all stability all purpose
no this consolation mindset lets you
find a way where you can stand out as a
star and yet fit into something bigger
namely a constellation i one of the
things that i love about this idea of a
constellation mindset
regardless of where we are in the
hierarchy and there's still hierarchy
um is to look out at the people we work
with our team
and and you see everybody as a star as
you've as you
as you just said and what i love about
that from a mindset perspective is it
forces someone
whether uh whether you're seeing
somebody who's who's higher in the
hierarchy or learn the hierarchy it
forces you to try and see their talents
because that's that when you talk about
the constellation mindset
it's the requirement to look for
someone's talent so you can see that
they
are a star it's not this philosophical
idea everyone's a star
kumbaya let's all hold hands and sit
around a campfire um
it's it's the it's the requirement that
you look for someone's talents and
understand how they fit in
to this constellation and make make a
bright point which which i absolutely
love
and found myself doing since you taught
me about it
cool ralph w asks how do i apply
the constellation mindset if i'm a
low-level
employee do i have to convince my
higher-ups
to adapt to this mindset you do not have
to convince your
quote i have to put them in air quotes
higher ups because i really once you get
this consolation mindset in
you you reject all forms of the pyramid
so
uh so yes i know what you mean rob um
no you can begin this we all can begin
this like right away at our next meeting
and
expectations into that meeting one and
then simon was just making this
this is i think i might have lost you
yeah you're you're cutting in a um
i'm gonna this is like i'm still on and
yeah
matthew's uh wi-fi sucks
um that is the hierarchy attempting to
shut him down
uh that's what that is that is top-down
leadership
in action uh so
i'll do what i can um based on what i
know of matthew's work
we have a good question from kelly go
ahead kelly go ahead kelly kelly says
she sees a lot of correlation between
the pyramid mindset and a fixed mindset
from the infinite game yeah
and a constellation mindset and an
infinite mindset yeah are they the same
or are there differences so kelly said
that she sees a lot of uh comparisons
between the fixed mindset of a pyramid
and the finite mindset that i write
about
and the infinite game and uh a
constellation mindset are they the same
thing
they're not the same thing but they are
absolutely related matthew
i'm just answering your question about
the correlation between the pyramid and
the infinite game
i like it when you explain it better so
we took a question
um uh there are similar but they're not
the same matthew and i clearly
um love each other's works because we
see
how our works relate to each other
absolutely
um to have an infinite mindset helps you
see
uh the constellation because you
understand that this is infinite
that um that the stars are ever
expanding
they're ever changing you can see new
patterns and new constellations
all the time um and whereas the
the the when you have a finite mindset
you view your organization as fixed
and you view people in fixed roles and
and um and fixed responsibilities even
um uh and so yes i think having having
an infinite mindset absolutely helps you
embrace
a constellation mindset and the more you
embrace a consolation mindset
um the easier it becomes to to operate
with an infinite mindset
they are not the same but they are
definitely correlated
uh would you agree matthew i know you
agree i i totally agree
and i think i left ralph w stranded is
that true did i
how do ralph w asked how do i apply the
constellation mindset
if i'm a lower level employee do i have
to convince my higher-ups to adopt this
mindset
you do not have to wait you can begin at
your next meeting
if you bring in three expectations into
that meeting
expectation number one expect to need
others
right expect to need the other stars um
number two expect to be needed
right you you are the only one who can
bring your truth to that meeting
and if you don't bring yourself you know
that's denying
um a unique thing that only you can
contribute
and those are really important but the
most important one is number three
expect to be changed and what i mean by
that
is if you have made this meeting
one in which this group has made
something together made a constellation
as i like to put it
um you cannot help but be a different
person at the end of that meeting than
you were
in the beginning and everyone will be
like that
because when you make something together
you're part of it it's part of you
but you're not diminished you're still
your own self you're just a little
richer for it
and you bring that into the next meeting
and so on and i
if you do that that is such a powerful
and unusual um way of conducting
ourselves
that that news will start to spread
you'll want to do it again the people in
that meeting with you will want to do it
again
and it can start to spread out what
you're proposing
sounds it's definitely simple
but i think it's actually more difficult
than than it sounds
because what you're asking people to do
is show up to every meeting with an open
mind and humility
um uh i am valued
and i value others and to your your your
third point that i can be changed which
is i don't
i'm no longer seeing uh uh my point of
view as
right versus wrong but rather simply as
a point of view as a point of light
um and the constellation may change the
pattern may change
i may change my mind but to that that is
was there a point is there something
that happened in your career
or was it an evolution was it an event
that
helped you learn to approach a meeting
with that level of humility that i walk
into a meeting
accepting that i can be changed and i
may be changed
i i can't point to one particular
meeting but the pattern
that i saw repeating over and over again
was a bunch
of smart people i liked
just trying to win arguments all the
time and it was kind of exhausting and
i'd watch it and then i
remember and simon you and i joked about
this it's like hey try this
everyone at your next meeting quick show
of hands how many people here like to
lose an argument
no one ever raises their hand
okay well the show must go on um
uh so uh matthew talked about this when
i did the podcast with him
that uh nobody ever goes into a meeting
uh nobody ever says i want to lose an
argument
um you know he said quick show of hands
who wants to lose an argument nobody
ever wants to
nobody ever uh wants to lose um
and this is the problem which is we're
all showing up to win
um and when you're talking about um
different colors
in an argument there's no such thing as
winning hopefully when he comes back
he'll tell us the rest of that story
uh graham do we have another question
that i can field
while matthew unfortunately gets all
stressed out
back home about his broken wi-fi even
though we're having fun
yeah we do asks what's the best way to
align personality tests with leadership
skills
uh sadaf asks what's the best way to
align uh personality types with
leadership skills
that's a great question i think much as
too much is made
of personality types and some being
better organized for leadership versus
another
now the reality is we all have strengths
and weaknesses and this is why i think
that
teamwork is actually the big thing it
actually goes to matthew's point quite
frankly which is to come into a meeting
knowing that others are valuable and i
am valued
um and that's the most important uh uh
that's the most important thing
and so i think when you learn those
those
uh strengths and weaknesses it helps you
understand the kind of teammate you can
be and what you can bring to a team
and it's great to learn what other
strengths if you do strengths finders or
one of the other
uh um uh you know enneagram whatever
whatever your thing is
uh uh it's fun to know uh how the others
show up on the team as well so i think
it's very important to learn those
things whatever your preferences
whatever
format you like to use it's very
important to understand the others and
you want to make sure that you have
different strengths on the team
i've seen this happen where you know uh
that we put all one kind of personality
type on a team
and the reality is different tasks
require different things now as it
relates to leadership
again it's understanding your
personality type and how to leverage all
of that stuff
to help others but the principles of
leadership are
unchanged regardless of your personality
type they remain completely separated
there's someone at my front door it's
probably fedex
okay it's just one of those days matthew
you were telling the story
of nobody who wants to uh when you say a
show quick show of hands
uh who wants to lose an argument yeah
and no one raises their hand right and
so why do we trick ourselves or tell
ourselves or train the next generation
to think that we're in the argument
winning business
it's just not i mean there's a time and
place for that i get that but like most
of what we're doing in meetings is
trying to make stuff together
and not trying to win so i guess that i
watched a series of that
and it just seems like it just became
exhausting everyone pretending that they
had the right
answer and trying to win there must be
some alternative so i was on the search
to find an alternative
i i you know this is something that i
think you and i have coming at the same
uh coin from two sides um where you talk
about the fact that we've
perhaps done ourselves a disservice by
teaching each other teaching ourselves
that the goal is to win an argument
because nobody wants to lose one um and
and
and i talk about it in terms of over
indexing and rugged individualism
it's me and i have to be the strongest i
have to be the smartest i have to hit
all my numbers otherwise
i am not not going to get promoted um
and i think one of the things we you and
i both advocating for
is actually teamwork is actually way
better to advance anything
whether it's thinking ideas production
process progress
all of these things are just better when
we work together and and the idea of
the idea of trying to win as an
individual all the time
actually does damage to the organization
and trying to win as a company all the
time
damage to economies and and whatnot
exactly and that's why
win-win although it's so tempting and we
say that win-win is a losing formula
go unpack that for me
i know because it sounds right again for
like a little bit but
just once you invoke winning you get
losing for free it just comes along
it's a package deal um
and and you framed it as a finite game
the minute you've done that
interesting what what language do i use
when i'm about to go into a negotiation
other than win-win
or or is that finite and that's allowed
yeah well once you've sort of accepted
it as a capital n negotiation
you know that is sort of a finite game
but if you just say hey what are we
going to be making together
we might be making decisions it's not
always a physical product but like
we are going to make this and you think
about it
you know covered recall this public
policy stuff climate change that people
are wrestling with
damn it this is this is a really
significant point
which is the idea of when you sit down a
negotiation table and you cut you
even if you're a well-intended
negotiator you say let's get to a
win-win
we're still thinking about ourselves i'm
on one side of the win equation
and the other party is on the other side
of the win equation and what i really
really like
is that you say what are we going to
make together
um so it's not about my win and your win
which are two separate
you know self-licking ice creams um um
but rather what are we going to make
together which i which i really
i that's such a wonderful way to start
to start a negotiation what are we going
to make together
and then you start to realize that the
the the points that i'm arguing will
hurt that process
exactly i really love that
we got a great question in the chat from
teresa who asks
how do you feel servant leadership
differs to giving away power
teresa asks how what's the difference
between servant leadership and giving
away power
oh okay um before my internet kicks out
again um
you have you have seven seconds go yeah
exactly
so sorry guys um we just said when you
when you were off we said
this is proof that the hierarchy is
trying to shut you down
it's the period very
okay so um
i think at its core um servant
leadership lots to love about that term
and about the people who feel attracted
to that term i'm one of them
i i just think that it it ends up i
think
making us think that this is a selfless
act
right this is selflessness and there's
this wonderful uh woman who taught me a
story i'm going to pass on very quickly
named lynn twist she's an amazing woman
she's helping save the rainforest
she takes a four-day trek through the
amazon to the headwaters of the
headwaters of the amazon meets with the
tribal chief she thinks the organization
can help
she makes her pitch about that help and
the tribal leader through a translator
says i think i understand
thank you uh if you're here to help
please leave
and you know like any of us she would
just like totally defeat it like i blew
it and then he continues but
if you're here to if you're here because
you think your liberation is inexorably
tied up with our liberation sits they
let's
work through this together and that
difference between helping
and mutual getting free together mutual
liberation whatever words sometimes that
turns people off but
being free together is the challenge is
the work
um and often selflessness is greeted
with
if you're here to help please leave so
that's the distinction i would make
is so here's so i'm gonna i want to
is there a unpack this with me this is
the thought that went through my mind
is there a hubris to the concept of
servant leadership
yes and i say this as a progressive you
know democrat my politics are pretty
well known but but
it's that awful tone that that people
can take and i've unfortunately taken it
in my life which is sort of has that
implied like you're welcome
which is just so it's just so
off-putting yeah like
and it's you know
allow me to help you it's kind of that
right there's a lot of condescension in
it there's a lot of pyramid stuff
there's a lot of like i'll help those at
the bottom like
that's so good it goes back to the point
you made some moments ago which i think
is such a great way to enter a meeting
is
you know what can we make together you
know what uh you know
which is not servant leadership it needs
we need i guess it's constellation
leadership
um it needs a new word because to your
point servant leadership is still
inexorably linked and actually tied up
uh
with with the pyramid i think so
love that uh how's your internet should
i do another question
i mean let's just we're holding together
right flip the coin roll today i love it
all right let's keep going ahmad k asks
what do you think is the biggest thing
standing in the way of companies
and countries success today go smaller
nice little question for you there the
pyramidamod
the pyramid and not some hierarchy out
there
it is inside each and every one of us i
told this story to simon on his uh
awesome podcast
um but if you ask 10 people what is the
opposite of winning to get them warmed
up they all say and unison losing and
then you say okay now the more
interesting question what's the opposite
of winning and losing
nine out of 10 of us say not playing
sitting it out
one in 10 of us says playing or being
learning laughing all these other things
that we do and enjoy in life that aren't
strictly winning and losing
that pyramid within us this is the world
of
up down in out ranking rating sorting
sifting
that world that is the biggest
impediment for countries companies
and each of us personally which i think
ties perfectly to what you said some
moments ago about being willing to be
changed because when you first told me
that story
i remember thinking how depressing that
only one out of ten people
uh say playing versus uh versus not
playing
when asked the opposite of winning and
losing they'd say playing
um i thought that was depressing and
then you you correct him you said no no
no
as soon as one person says playing
everybody else goes
oh yeah and then you convert the other
nine people
and so the idea of being willing to
showing up even if you have a point of
view about something is fine but we
willing to show up and say i can be
changed i think is required in that
in that and we lost matthew again okay
um i'm going to answer this one from my
perspective because
it's the question and he's not here um
why do you think so many leaders
struggle with delegating or giving away
power
uh matthew we're going to take turns
asking
answering this question why do you think
so many leaders struggle with delegating
or giving away power
i think there's a couple of things one
is fear
especially when you're you know mo
if you're in if you're at a senior
position you used to be at a middle
and lower position that's how we that's
how you make your way up the pyramid
right
um and so we're we're all used to being
doers
and we get good at something which is
what gets us promoted
and then we get promoted to oversee the
people who do the job we used to do
and that's an entirely different skill
set and so it's very very difficult to
let go
of something and allow somebody to try
something fail
not do it as well as us especially when
we are better at doing their job because
that's what god has promoted
and so part of it is education we don't
teach people
the the skill of leadership so that when
they achieve a position of leadership
when they're offered a position of
leadership they actually are more
equipped to let go because they
understand that's not my job anymore and
they
and if there's an infinite mindset to
say by letting go
i might see the numbers go down because
this person isn't as good as me
but by allowing them to learn and learn
and learn the numbers will come back up
and more importantly
now we have two people who are really
good at this and when we do that
we're going to give it to somebody else
who doesn't know how to do it and then
you have three people who know how to do
it
and that way if one person's at sick or
leaves for a better job opportunity
you're not stuck because you took the
small dips to prevent a big dip
so i think i think fear is one of them
is one of one of the reasons we
struggle to delegate uh i guess the
other one is it just feels good to be in
charge so ego
um and the other one is is education we
don't teach people
how to let go we don't teach people how
to lead matthew you want to take a stab
at it why
uh what is the question no i got it okay
i mean i i think yeah i agree with
everything you said and i just to add to
it i think
it is a perspective and that when you
say
uh delegating there's often
in the mind of a leader this idea of
like sharing power like who could be
against that and yet the leaders and i
talk about some of these in the book
these amazing leaders most of whom we've
never heard of
they saw something the rest of us missed
which is
power obviously shouldn't be lorded over
other people afforded to yourself and
all that
but they went farther like power
shouldn't even be shared in the sense of
divvying up
because they saw power not as something
that's like a scarce resource that you
mine
they saw power as something you make
like we talked about earlier
once you see power is something you make
and you only can make with other people
then it's a different way of framing
like hey you've got x amount of power
why don't you share it with your team
and fundamentally that's like invokes a
lot of loss and like oh i guess i'm
gonna have less
and when you were saying and your answer
was so great it's like and then two and
then three
so it can multiply and multiplication
and division in this context are very
different
i think this is worth underscoring
because i think this is so good and and
i know we called your book the power of
giving away
power but it's you know it's partially
done for
for we want a a good title that's that's
that's that's intriguing
but in in some way shape or form it it
plays on on old
on old misunderstandings and
misperceptions of power
when you think of power as an infinite
resource which i think is so fascinating
when you say giving away power
i'm actually not giving away anything
i'm not taking my power and giving my
power to you and now i have less power
i'm i'm simply i retain all of my power
and
i'm giving you some as well it's lifting
well
and it's sort of like you give it and
then you just get it back and then you
give it again and you get it back and it
just
multiplies and grows but but it is
misunderstood
it's so funny like my whole career up
until now i have studiously avoided
ever using the word power in diplomacy
business politics
and now i use it twice in a short time
twice in one title yeah
but i think that's what you're doing i
think you're challenging the definitions
of power which is what i love which is
what i love about your work
um yan s or it could be janus
depending on where they're from i don't
know
uh uh what's the relationship between
what's that
why don't we go with you then there's
okay they're scandinavian
um yeah what's the relationship between
the infinite mindset and the
constellation mindset
i took a crack at that when you logged
off um but i want you i want to hear
your point of view
actually i don't want to hear your point
of view so never mind
you back matthew do i have you
oh gosh so close
so close this next question says for
matthew
sorry tony um what else do we have
um uh we've got one here from shane
go ahead shane yes how do you try and
convince older generations that their
strengths
are still strengths in a changing
culture moving forward
oh you oh i want you to tackle this one
matthew i'm gonna how do you convince
i struggle with that word but we'll get
to that in a moment how do you convince
an older generation
that their strengths are still strength
even in
a changing cultural world
oh i want to see what you say to that
one simon um
i you know i i got um
i lost the connection when when we got
that great question
about personality types which i loved
your answer
and didn't have anything to add to that
i was thinking about
um here's a visual aid while i last if
you go make an org chart
you go make an org chart literally i
think in microsoft powerpoint which is
what i use
office it says org chart hierarchy is
the default right it's a bunch of boxes
that make it super easy
i of course i'm allergic to pyramids so
i don't make org charts that way
and so i've been making my own org
charts in powerpoint for a long time
and if you've done it you make little
circles and then you put those things
called
connectors and there's a point you were
making about personality types
when you put it up when you put a
connector which is like a line in
microsoft but it's a line that like
tries to find a shape
when you get it near the shape the shape
lights up and it has like
six connection points that you could
possibly attach that line to
yeah and i think about that in the
context of personality types i think
that
in the context of this last question
around the strengths they have like
connect to their strength just find it
it's it's
it's there if you look at them as a 360
degree thing
don't force it in this side find the
thing and then
let it connect to a different star that
way to get sort of abstract
but once again you know i think part of
being a star in the constellation
is not only seeing yourself as a star
because we're all pretty good at that
uh but it's seeing other people as a
star as well and i think it goes back to
your point of humility before which is
it's the humility of an older generation
to say that young generations do bring
something to the table that i may not
know
but and and it's also for younger
generations to say
older generations have something that i
don't have and and to connect the
generational
uh points of view is more powerful than
i'm right and you're wrong
well that's right we talked about this
when you came to the embassy many moons
ago in london that
our governments and this is not unique
to governments we tend to put on these
blinders and we really love people sort
of aged 30 to 60. we don't pay attention
to them before
we sort of tune them out after 65 and
they're some of the most interesting
people i've ever met are the older
generation
and the younger ones and so widening the
aperture factoring
them in and the other thing i think that
gets in the way is this platitude
that we say which is what unites us is
greater than what divides us
and i know what people mean i've said
that but this consolation mindset is
like no no
lots of energy and potential energy
lives indifference
as long as we constructively engage the
difference
and make something with that difference
so we should be seeking out
difference from the older generation
from the younger generation and
and making meaning out of it it really
is this magical connection between
naivete and wisdom and i think do
explain i think arguably the people who
we
listen to and we're all guilty of it
which is that 30 to 60
right have neither naivete or wisdom
because they've lost their knowledge oh
that's good and they're not yet old
enough for experience enough to be wise
because they're still in the game
but when they leave the game and they
can look back it's like i love the movie
um
uh the fog of war which is this extended
uh
uh interview with robert mcnamara and
what's amazing is
people have visceral hatred for robert
mcnamara for all the right reasons
given he's the architect of the vietnam
war but when you listen to this old wise
man
who now is no longer in the game be able
to look back and criticize himself and
his actions and have
perspective that he didn't have when he
was in the game you it's very hard to
hate him
and realize what he brings to the table
is wisdom
um somebody who's under 30 has
unbelievable naivete
they believe they can change the world
i'm going to start a business and it's
going to change business and you think
about all of the companies that
actually did change the world the apples
the microsoft they were all started by
20-somethings if not younger facebook
was started by a college student
right and it's like because they're so
naive to believe
that they can that it sets them up for
for that opportunity
and they're not encumbered by the old
ways of doing things
so i think to bring unconstrained
thinking with the perspective of wisdom
and and to your point broad broad
blinders
because i think what happens between 30
and 60 is the blinders go in
i think before 30 and above 60 the
blinders actually open up again for
different reasons
and i and i think that's a really
interesting point of view
well i do too and back to fog of war i
think it's errol morris who the amazing
documentary filmmaker
we talk a lot about language i'm
obsessed with it because words make
worlds and all that i do believe that i
know you do too it's like
the body language that we use and and i
don't know the details but it's worth
everyone googling how he makes his films
he has this technique where the person
robert mcnamara
he's i think looking at the filmmaker
not looking at a blank camera
looking at a blank screen you have to do
it all the time in your work simon is a
weird thing just like in zoom
looking at a picture of yourself all day
long
is weird and it does weird things to you
so
makes you keep treating your hair yeah
exactly he he
or maher did something very clever with
the body language of film to bring that
out of to sort of yeah from robert
mcnamara this this wisdom
that if you feel back in the corner
you'll fold your arms and
give the same answer you've given for 30
years not interested
and even now talking to you like i'm
trying to look at you
which unfortunately because the
placement of the camera makes me look
like i'm looking down
and if i'm going to change the camera to
make eye contact with an audience i'm
not looking at you and it feels weird
and so i'm constantly jostling between
the two because i'm trying to have a
conversation with you
but recognizing that there's an audience
so i hear what you're saying and that's
even more extreme which is the ability
to
form human connection right that's what
errol morris does
for those who haven't seen fog of war it
did win an oscar
uh not that that's a reason to see it
but it is absolutely brilliant uh i
think his best work if you ask me errol
morris not
robert mcnamara um
[Music]
although arguably robert mcnamara is
best moving right on my future yeah
yeah let's move on uh okay uh
jada h um oh this is a good one for you
matthew
i love this because you've just you've
just got done writing your book
uh what is the hardest part of
distilling all of your experiences and
ideas
into one book brutal
um so hard really hard
you should find a simon cynic in your
life because boy do they make it worth
the work and to give that early
encouragement so
so you use the word um jada uh
distillation which i'm dialing in semi
successfully from kentucky we love to
make whiskey
and there are three steps to make
whiskey and the first one's fermentation
the second one's distillation and the
third one
the trivia question you normally say
aging but it's
maturation okay so distillation is
really important but step number one
is fermentation you bubble up all these
ideas and if you have a loving
um critical friend a good sense of that
word i like the word critical
like critics count they do they're
wonderful loving critics are hugely
important
simon read my first offering which was
three times as long
and you were just wonderfully accepting
of it you're like i'm glad you did this
but
i'm not interested in that book but
there are ideas in it if you could
distill those down
and weave them together in a different
way not chronologically i'd be
interested
and so it took a long long time it was
really hard um and it did feel
like distillation but fermentation
bubbling up comes first
i think oh i love this i love the
analogy of whiskey
where the first of the fermentation the
bubbling up and that's exactly what you
do to write
a book i mean the process that i use
that i think you adopted
it's not for everyone but it's the
process i use is i buy blank index cards
no lines
and i just there they are and i just
have i just
i just i allow the fermenting i just any
idea that comes to mind that i think is
related
even even if it's by a loose thread
uh i i write it down and it doesn't have
to be in full sentences it's just to
remind me so that i know what it is
and i walk around with my stack of index
cards and every time i have an idea or a
story that might work i put it down it's
it's a it's a fermenting
and then the distillation is i take this
stack of cards and i start organizing
them
and seeing if i can tell a story and
what belongs what doesn't belong
and then the maturation is the ability
to tell the story over and over and over
again until it makes sense
look at that who knew that whiskey was
actually
uh a means to writing a book
uh this one is from tony b and it says
for matthew
uh what is your why and how does the
constellation mindset
fit in no
[Laughter]
[Music]
so good just as i said for matthew he's
gone
um we'll get him back we'll answer this
one question
and then we'll spare everybody the
torture and we'll we'll call it a day
okay matthew the last question was
actually for matthew so i couldn't
i couldn't answer no he's uh tony b asks
what is your why
and how does the constellation mindset
fit into that
oh okay um i'm debuting my why
uh here which seems appropriate with
this wonderful group of
uh fellow simon cynic uh fans
well the the image you know simon loves7
image so i brought them here
the image is a big boat and a little
boat which one
i got to do my why with simon which was
really cool um and you can hear that
story on his podcast with me so i won't
repeat it here
before the internet clips out but mine
is to encourage people to see how they
can stand out
and fit in at the same time so that we
can build
more bigger better things together
beautiful
uh and how does that fit into the
constellation mindset
well it is so standing out and fitting
in is what you are in a constellation
and i'll close for those of you who are
american
um and i think it's much bigger than
america i think the best idea of america
is summed up in our latin phrase e
pluribus unum
from many one we talked about the
pyramid you could think of that as from
many bricks one pyramid
which would be incredibly depressing you
either fit in or you're left out
but that is not what the founders did
euphorbis unum is right underneath the
constellation
on our national motto which is right
above the eagle's head i'm not having it
i'm spatially challenged here there you
go it's that thing above the eagle's
head
e pluribus written under the
constellation from many stars one
constellation stand out as a star
fit into a larger constellation that i
think is what i want to
devote my life to trying to do i love
that
matthew barzen thank you for taking the
time thanks for enduring
uh wi-fi thank you everybody else for
doing the same thank you thank you
uh if you're interested in more of
matthew's work which i highly highly
highly highly recommend he's been highly
influential
in my growth uh check out his new book
the power of giving away power
uh sold in fine bookstores anywhere and
some not so fine ones if i might be
honest
um uh you can visit the link in the
description or the link
we're dropping in the chat to learn more
about matthew and his work
you can also check out the episode that
he and i recorded together in a bit of
optimism
where we have a lovely conversation
about cell phones and all kinds of cool
things that are influenced by
constellation thinking matthew barzun
always a joy always a joy thank you so
much for taking the time
thank you simon thank you and thank you
everyone for putting up with my sketchy
um connection
really really grateful bye everyone see
you soon